imaginemos que vivimos en un mundo muy
simplificado en el que tenemos dos
países
cada uno es capaz de producir manzanas o
plátanos o una combinación de ambos lo
que esta tabla nos indica es que si el
país
pone toda su energía en producir
manzanas en un día podría producir tres
y si pone toda su energía en producir
plátanos en un día podría producir seis
del mismo modo si el país ve pone toda
su energía en producir manzanas en un
día podría producir dos y si pone toda
su energía en producir plátanos en un
día podría producir cuatro una vez que
sabemos esto nos preguntamos quién tiene
la ventaja comparativa en manzanas y
quién tiene la ventaja comparativa en
plátanos y cómo deberían comerciar pausa
en el vídeo y tratan de averiguarlo
bien cuando pensamos en una ventaja
comparativa en realidad también nos
estamos preguntando cuál es el costo de
oportunidad de producir una manzana y
cuál es el costo de oportunidad de
producir un plátano en cada país vamos a
poner una pequeña sub columna aquí para
el costo de oportunidad
el costo de oportunidad de una manzana
en el país
para producir tres manzanas el país a
tendrá que dejar de producir seis
plátanos esto quiere decir que por cada
manzana va a dejar de producir dos
plátanos dos plátanos por manzana y el
costo de oportunidad de los plátanos
simplemente va a ser el recíproco de eso
media manzana por plátano podemos hacer
un cálculo similar para el país ve y
quizás se den cuenta de que algo
interesante está a punto de suceder cuál
es el costo de oportunidad de las
manzanas en el país ve una manera de
plantearlo es si produce dos manzanas
quiere decir que deja de producir cuatro
plátanos o sea que deja de producir dos
plátanos por cada manzana si queremos
pensar en términos del costo de
oportunidad de los plátanos para
producir cuatro plátanos el país ve deja
de producir dos manzanas esto es la
mitad de una manzana por plátano lo
interesante es que ambos países tienen
el mismo costo de oportunidad de
manzanas en términos de plátanos y
también tienen el mismo costo de
oportunidad de plátanos en términos de
manzanas
y debido a que ambos tienen los mismos
costos de oportunidad no existe una
ventaja comparativa vamos a escribir
mismos costos de oportunidad
ninguno tiene ventaja comparativa
tomando como base a nuestro modelo que
es muy sencillo no hay ganancias en el
comercio vamos a visualizarlo de otra
manera que tal vez nos permita
entenderlo más claramente
voy a trazar un eje aquí bien este es mi
otro eje el eje horizontal va a ser el
eje de las manzanas y el eje vertical va
a ser el eje de los plátanos esto es por
díaz plátanos y manzanas por día si el
país
pone toda su energía en producir
manzanas podría producir una dos tres
manzanas en un día si pone toda su
energía en producir plátanos podría
producir 246 podría producir seis en un
día si suponemos que este es un
intercambio de producción lineal sus
posibilidades de producción tendrían el
aspecto de una línea recta la pendiente
sería el costo de oportunidad cada vez
que aumentamos una manzana disminuimos
dos plátanos por lo que esta situación
se trata de una pendiente negativa es
igual
a menos dos plátanos por manzana esta
pendiente se basa en como escogí los
ejes y nos proporciona el costo de
oportunidad de las manzanas en términos
de plátanos cuántos plátanos se dejan de
producir cada que aumentamos una manzana
ese es nuestro costo de oportunidad
ahora bien el país ve puede producir 4
plátanos 2 manzanas o alguna cantidad
intermedia pero observemos que tiene
exactamente la misma pendiente la
pendiente es el costo de oportunidad si
intercambiamos los ejes la pendiente
será el costo de oportunidad de los
plátanos en términos de manzanas pero la
conclusión más importante es que si
vemos las posibilidades de producción de
dos países que producen dos bienes y
ambos tienen la misma pendiente quiere
decir que sus costos de oportunidad van
a ser iguales y no va a haber ganancias
en el comercio recuerden que el objetivo
de la ventaja comparativa y el comercio
es que ambos países se beneficien pero
existen situaciones en las que ninguno
se beneficia porque ambos tienen el
mismo costo de oportunidad este fue un
ejemplo en otro ejemplo vemos que a
veces un país
puede tener una ventaja comparativa
sobre el otro pero aunque tengan
distintos costos de oportunidad no hay
ganancias en el comercio tal vez de
algún modo cada uno desconoce los costos
de oportunidad del otro o por alguna
razón no comercial tal vez sin importar
lo que indiquen los modelos sobre la
ventaja comparativa un país diga yo no
quiero producir plátanos las manzanas
son el futuro esta es una industria más
especializada o cualquier otra cosa
definitivamente existen situaciones
incluso en nuestro modelo que es muy
simplificado en las que probablemente no
existen ganancias en el comercio la más
típica por supuesto es cuando no hay
ventaja comparativa y ambos países
tienen los mismos costos de oportunidad
en los bienes que producen nos vemos en
el siguiente vídeo